start by imagining a tropical Lagoon to
the fish that live here this watery
world is all there is this Lagoon is
their entire universe
they have no idea there's anything
beyond well they are fish and that
theirs is actually just one of a huge
number of bodies of water on Earth's
surface some like theirs and some very
different so now that you are a fish
what if you got a clue that this world
of ours is just a tiny Lagoon in
something much bigger could your fish
brain handle that we humans always
assumed our universe is one of a kind
unique even the word universe reflects
this we think that one and only universe
came into existence nearly 14 billion
years ago with what's called the Big
Bang in the 1980's a group of young
physicists including Andrei Linde Paul
Steinhardt
andreas Albrecht and Alan Guth came up
with an enhanced version of the Big Bang
Theory they proposed that in the first
instant after the Big Bang the universe
underwent a burst of incredibly rapid
expansion called inflation
and satellite measurements of the heat
left over from the Big Bang now support
the idea but surprisingly the theory of
inflation also suggested something very
high according to inflation the Big Bang
that created our universe may not have
been a one-time event instead it could
have happened again and again and again
an infinite number of times and just as
our Big Bang created our universe each
of those Big Bang's would have created
other universes a process that would
continue eternally so Guth Linda and
others concluded that instead of a
universe we might be living in a
multiverse the math shows it's always
the math right that the multiverse would
contain a huge variety of universes
ranging from some that are nothing like
ours to others with duplicates of earth
and each and every one of us in fact the
existence of so many other universes
would mean everything that can happen
will happen in one universe or another
it's an intriguing out of the pond idea
but also controversial igniting a fierce
debate in the scientific community
several scientists including some who
helped create the theory of inflation
have come up with counter arguments to
the multiverse
a theory that predicts everything
predicts nothing one road and critics
object that considering the multiverse
is more akin to philosophy that science
so who is right about the multiverse we
all know how our fishtail would turn out
if those fish could find a way to see
beyond their lagoon they would discover
that their universe is not unique and
the Earth's surface is covered with
lagoons ponds lakes seas and oceans
teeming with all kinds of creatures this
discovery would forever change their
picture of reality but what about us
what would it mean to find were part of
a much larger multiverse
how seriously should we take this idea
and what if I just zapped out of this 2d
multiverse it appeared before you right
now